Bohemian Rhapsody will rock you or at
least Rami Malik's performance in the
film well 20th Century Fox screened
Bohemian Rhapsody the musical drama
biopic centered on the legendary rock
band Queen and it's even more iconic
frontman Freddie Mercury for press and
critics on Sunday October 7th in Los
Angeles those in attendance of since
shared online their first reactions to
the film the verdict Bohemian Rhapsody
is largely enjoyable if not pretty
cookiecutter as far as biopics go
and while Indy wires and Thompson
expects a film to get mixed reviews it
appears everyone agrees am Alex Turner's
Freddie Mercury
it's a dazzling sight to behold many
even Kyle Buchanan of the New York Times
who called the film a glorified
Wikipedia entry have praised Malik's
performance as being out-of-this-world
incredible in fact they're already
placing bets on Malick receiving an
Oscar nomination for Best Actor for his
work ass weekly film critic Mara
Weinstein tweeted how do you turn an
okay movie into a good one five words
rami malek as Freddie Mercury hashtag
Bohemian Rhapsody Jenna Bush the founder
and editor-in-chief of legion of lair
was also completely swept away tweet
saying absolutely beyond blown away by
Bohemian Rhapsody Rami Malek is
phenomenal gorgeous story amazing
concert movie I don't have enough words
more honor bash to praise came from film
critic Scott mance who exclaimed
holy hell Bohemian Rhapsody is
absolutely fantastic
a rousing emotional cinematic champion
that will rock you Rami Malek is
magnificent it's great fun and it will
rock you a star is born you've been
served in the eyes of many critics
Malick went above and beyond in his
interpretation of mercury you don't want
to mimic Freddie you want to be able to
understand why he did what he did
playing a real-life figure is never an
easy task for actors no matter how much
they look like the people they portray
the Malick stepping into Mercury's shoes
meant more than just putting on an
accent rocking eccentric costumes and
wearing false teeth I gave him Mercury's
famous overbite you can pop them and pop
them out but I chose to keep them in for
the majority of the shoot really yeah
even at lunch you
according to Entertainment Weekly Mallik
practice singing Queen songs every night
while wearing the fake chompers before
Fox even greenlit Bohemian Rhapsody and
poured over Mercury's past interviews
and performances the actor even took a
trip to London financed entirely out of
pocket before Bohemian Rhapsody had even
received funding to conduct research
Malick met with Queen drummer Roger
Taylor and lead guitarist Brian May dug
into biographies and watched old footage
of mercury
additionally Malick worked with movement
coach Polly Bennett's to capture
Mercury's unique physicality and
collaborated with choreographers ahead
of filming to ensure he was as prepared
as he could be speaking to Vanity Fair
Malick shared that Bennett would have
him quotes two ludicrous things like ski
across the room in efforts to mimic
Mercury's signature onstage theatrics
Malick essentially studied every little
thing mercury did he explained I watched
the way his lips moved while he was
singing and everything that's happening
in his throat in his vocal chords sounds
like all that hard work paid off once
[ __ ] lifts a review embargo a few days
ahead of the film's release some
opinions about Bohemian Rhapsody are
sure to change for now although the
initial responses are promising decide
for yourself whether Bohemian Rhapsody
is a Killer Queen or just a bunch of
Radio gaga when the movie debuts on
November 2nd
[Applause]
[Music]